hello and welcome to cloud on-air live
webinars for Google cloud my name is
Soleil Kelly and I'm a product marketer
on Google cloud specifically focused on
data visualization and business
intelligence and joining me is I'm Dave
Olson a product manager on Google data
studio right keep in mind you can ask
questions at any time throughout this
presentation we have some Googlers on
standby to answer them and we'll have a
live Q&A at the end of the presentation
so today I'm very excited to be talking
about data and specifically how we're
communicating with data and how that's
really changed over time I mean data is
so much more embedded in our day-to-day
lives and and woven into the fabric of
our conversations and it's really it's
it's just interesting how it's changed
so much over time and this is not just
internally throughout business in
organizations but externally to public
audiences online it's just it's
interesting times and then of course
this wouldn't be complete if we didn't
actually build a demo so we're gonna
also create a demo here on screen for
everybody so long before we have these
incredible devices in our hands we were
you know create we were pulling insights
from all kinds of places I mean I'm
looking at this photograph of a campfire
in the Pacific Northwest and thinking
about just way back when to find
insights if you were say a fisherman you
would take you know stock of your days
catch you would weave in stories that
were passed over the generations you
know across that campfire to create some
insights that you might use to figure
out what you're gonna do in your very
next day you know fast forwarding to
technology today and where we're at all
these incredible innovations have made
it so easy for us to be able to take
data from disparate places and weave
them together into these really
compelling stories so a single person
might be taking a matching data from
NOAA weather data and boat traffic and
potentially some aquatic survey data and
creating this compelling story online
share
it out maybe it's a story about
sustainability so really the the way in
which we can tell these stories online
has just dramatically dramatically
changed and that's just it's super
exciting to do this like even ten you
know five or ten years ago it used to
take a lot of people to actually create
these stories no today we know it can be
done much more single-handedly but you
know again ten years ago you would need
IT you would need data scientist
potentially some really hardcore
analysts maybe some developers for the
front end even designers to stand up
this story and to be able to push that
out online and that doesn't even mean
maintaining it to do that you would need
a lot of resources like time you would
need a lot of budget to do that as well
and that becomes really challenging
today we you know we're we're we've
introduced a product a couple years ago
it's called data studio again which Dave
is a product manager for and it's really
a product that is it's it's a free
product it's really designed for people
who analyze and work with data every day
who are analyte analyzing and
communicating that data out design from
the ground up to really make it super
easy to visualize to work with the data
and also to share that out it's
completely serverless
and scalable across Google's entire
infrastructure so that makes it really
easy for you to focus on the things that
matter most to you which is telling
stories and so what we've really done
with data studio is simplify that whole
process in the workflow so if you think
about accessing and connecting to your
data that process of analyzing it
visualizing and sharing that out we've
really simplified that process and so if
we think about the data sources I mean
that's one of the most common scenarios
that people are asking about is how do I
connect to this data or that data and
you can see on the on the screen so many
different sources on you know both from
the Google side like if you have your
data stored in places like bigquery or
GCS to even other places like your ad
performance data tons of different first
party Google data as well
a ton of sources available from our
fast-growing community of data
connections so over 300 sources
everything from you know reddit to
Salesforce to Facebook and many other
companies developers are building these
connections to new sources and that
really means that you have a lot more
access to the data that you care about
and what you want to be able to tell in
your story also worth mentioning on this
is the access that you have within
bigquery we have all of these public
data sets that you can use to be able to
weave into your own stories or to be
able to create new insights as well as
there are commercial data sets that you
can license as well and once you're all
set and done you've built the story and
you found those insights it's super easy
to be able to share that out to your
audiences and your stakeholders either
just a link to a report if that might be
internally you know it you know if you
want to keep your data protected and
just share that link internally and
nobody else would have access to it or
as an iframe embedded in your blog or
your website something like that so I
mentioned we're gonna build a demo today
and so of course we will be doing that
and just sending a little bit of context
for this demo this is a particular story
about a marketing team's success drafted
by the team lead her name is Maya and
she works at a company called foo hard
where she wanted to send out a pre read
ahead of a quarterly All Hands and so
just a simple scenario of like hey I
really want to motivate people to get to
this quarterly All Hands cuz attendance
has been really low she wanted everybody
to see the success of a couple of
programs that her team had been running
and specifically because it was it had
broad implications around an opportunity
for foo hardware she leads marketing
programs for all West Coast departments
of foo and despite being traditional
brick-and-mortar they stay pretty
current with new technologies one of
their analysts recently brought in a
bunch of data into bigquery my had heard
of it she wasn't too familiar with it
she spends most of her time in their crm
focusing on their customers and whatnot
so this is this is the story that might
actually sent out this was in the form
of a lake
again this is an internal stories this
is not something you know this is the
fou hardware's you know prep data they
want to protect they're not gonna be
brought passing this out online for
everybody to see so this is a really an
internal story that she's sharing here
directly within google studio and so
again she she starts her story with just
those those key metrics that she knows
everybody wants to see you know
everything is going great and she
invites people to go so go dive in and
take a look at the actual data itself so
here first she builds a very you know
sort of an overview a very basic
dashboard of company health looking at
the past year
departmental revenues a couple of
scorecards for profit and profit margin
and time series of how profit how
revenue is done over the last year and
again this is interactive so people
could be in here and playing with the
date controls and whatnot if they wanted
to so to her audience she's taking them
down this path she's telling a story
because again she wants to get them to
this quarterly allowance so everything's
looking good right but did you know who
was sitting on this massive opportunity
let's take a look at another slice of
the data looking at our top five states
so she creates a stack bar looking at
revenue across across the past year
broken by month for these top five
states and she also included a couple
filters so people you know in other
departments again she leads departments
on the West Coast territory but if other
folks wanted to kind of drill in and see
their own data they could do that and
here again guiding them down the path so
what specific opportunity are am I
trying to find here as the consumer of
the story pay me a picture tell me
what's going on so he or she then lays
out you know hey our team piloted this
marketing initiative in spring
specifically around paint across all the
geographies in California so let's take
a look at those specific results and so
here she drills it into just specific
paint she added a filter for this report
just to see the revenues for paint and
you can see very well that in that
springtime revenue was was was flying
highest it was doing really really well
people might have questions well is this
repeatable and she anticipates that and
and takes them down this path again so
they're also running this program in
appliances at the same time so here
she's showing those results that hey
this
working in appliances too and that's
fantastic so as the audience you know
she knows they have a lot of questions
and so she wants again to bring them to
the court quarterly all hands where her
team can share the successes and really
dive into the details of how they
achieve that and how they can unlock
this opportunity for from hardware so
again a real basic story and that's
that's our story completely built in
data studio and next Dave is gonna help
us walk through how Maya built this this
experience great thanks Ally
so I'll show how we helped Maya build
this great experience in data studio so
this is the data studio homepage and
there's reports these are a list of all
the reports that I have and then data
sources and data sources are just
connections to my underlying data so I
come over here on the Left I click on
data sources these are my existing data
sources but I want to create a new data
source and so it like Sally mentioned we
have connectors to many different data
so we have Google Performance ads
performance connectors like Adwords
YouTube Google Analytics we have cloud
connectors like Google Cloud Storage
bigquery cloud sequel and then we also
have more third-party connectors where
users can come in and actually build
their own connectors to any data around
the web so if if the question is is do
you connect to X the answer is usually
yes
so for this the purpose of this demo
will connect to bigquery like so I
mentioned we have public data sets so I
can come in here and I can enrich my
data in my reports with all the public
data sets that are available in bigquery
but for this demo we have our retail
data test retail data so I select
through there and then I just click
connect and so what we're doing right
now is we're making an underlying
connect a connection to the underlying
data and then now we have all the fields
and the schema of these fields so what
we've done here is we've looked and we
have Auto typed these fields so we know
for instance you know that month is a
month due this is a yyy mmdd date and we
also can come in here and override some
of these like so for year month we
didn't quite get this one so we'll
change this to your month and now once
we've done these fixes in the data
source we
here and we create a report so we add
our data source to the report and now we
can just start drawing we click on the
time series drag it across the page and
just like that we start visualizing data
so for here we want to look at your
month we'll just recreate the demo that
Maya made your month and then I search
for revenue I pull in revenue here and
now I'm looking at my revenue over the
last two years and actually let's also
we can adjust the page size here so that
it's the same size I think it was 800 by
400 slide size we'll move this up make
this a little smaller that's great and
then I can start adding controls on to
this page so I can stick a date range on
here and select a default date range
we'll look at last year for 2017 data
only and then when I do operations on
this date control or any filter controls
that I put on the page they
automatically apply to all the
components on the page so there's no
special bindings that I have to
configure out-of-the-box if I want to
group these together I can just select
them and group them together so they
only apply to these specific
visualizations so now let's keep going
we can recreate we'll stick a scorecard
on here for revenue great
I should style this so I can come in
here and click on the chip change the
format from number to a currency so
these are US dollars and let's clean
these up make these compact numbers
awesome and then we want to look at the
this compared to the previous period and
we've invested a lot in making the dates
a lot of different date functionality
and the dates very easy to use so for
here I can just do last year I can
compare this to the previous period so
now for any filter range that I apply to
this page we will look at that for the
previous period so if I want to look at
one week's worth of data will look at
that same week for the prior year or
last quarters worth of data will look at
q4 for last year as well automatically
so here I can go I've got revenue let's
put a couple more we'll change this one
to cost great I've got costs and then we
have another one down here for profit
profit dollars awesome I'll move this
one up and then so now I want to create
a field for profit margin which is just
profit dollars divided by revenue so for
here I can create new fields within the
data source so I come in here and I say
profit will call this profit percent and
then this is just profit dollars divided
by revenue and there's a lot of
different calculations that we can make
in here we can use case statements for
grouping we can create hyperlinks inside
of tables we can concatfile
there's a lot of different functionality
that we support within this formula
builder so here I create the field also
I've got a new profit percentage it
shows up immediately here I'll copy
paste this
pull this over profit percentage now I
want to show this as a percentage so I
just come in here for the type I change
the type to percent great so now also
this one if I recall correctly this was
actually below so we'll move this down
and then we'll create a bar chart here
see here we can change this to
Department and then this to revenue
and I'll change this to a horizontal bar
chart all right
so now I need a little I can change the
margin here so that we can see all of
the labels and now I need a little help
because I don't actually have the header
so maybe my colleague Soleil and a
different Department actually has all
the right marketing so now what's really
cool is this is all built on top of
Google Drive so the same technology that
allows users to collaborate on other
products like Google sheets or Google
Docs you can collaborate inside of data
studio using that same technology so I
come in here to share the report and
I'll share it with Salette demos they
spelled that correctly I so laid out
demos at gmail.com
please help with the brand logos so now
Soleil is getting an email notification
in this box letting him know that he can
come in and actually collaborate on this
report with me so silly can you go ahead
and click on that yeah it's going to
open it up
is it yeah untitled untitled report
having slight issue I'll just keep going
on here
so now I'll come back here and I'll just
grab the marketing from the top myself
great I can grab this image oops right
here and then the white background here
and then just like you can and any other
design you can send this to the back
pull this up to the top and I'll add a
text field this is mm - hard where
revenue
or Phu Hardware metrics so now I've
created this first slide on here showing
exactly what Maya has done and now it's
really easy to add what's us at a title
here through hardware now it's really
easy to add the rest of the pages as
well so I can add a new page let's title
this page rename metrics overview and
then page two will show let's see if I
can remember will show the top five
states by top five states department
revenue breakdown so I will actually I
can come back here and the metrics
overview I can make all of these
elements report level so now these
persists across all the pages in my
report so I don't have to recreate them
every time so great I have this food
Hardware metrics I draw a bar chart I
want to look at our year month
year month broken down by Department and
we'll look at this by revenue
we'll only look at the top five and we
can switch this to a horizontal and
looks like the date range is a little
bit too long so we'll add another date
range control here excellent and make
this till last year actually we can just
make this report level so we can go back
to our first page make this a report
level make report level and now this
persist across both pages and I have my
filters here and I should stack these
bars up it looks like so lays on here so
so like an you go to page two here and
can you change the title for me on this
page of course I can so now I now see we
see Salette up here on the screen and
this red this red box here shows up
Salette is actually editing this in real
time so this is this works not just if
we're sitting you know standing next to
each other in a webinar but this also
works if we're on opposite sides of the
world we can collaborate and edit a
report at the same time together now so
leis fixing up this the bar chart
together
so we'll go I'll change the margin up
moving it around I'll go work on the
next page well so late finishes this up
okay cool so now actually we'll just
make a copy of this page the top five
states so I will come back here I'll
duplicate this one a copy of page two
whoops
copy the wrong page
all right so now I've got this and we
want to look at this let's order this by
year month I'll do this year month
ascending or there we go great and now I
want to create a filter for this to look
at the category by paint only so now
this isn't a filter control that I want
to allow my users to switch around so I
create this filter at the at the report
level so we'll call this our paint
filter include category equal to and we
have lots of different operators that we
can apply it to filters so contain
starts with we have regex and and then
we can also create compound filters so
we have both hands and or filters that
you can use to create very complex
expressions so equal to paint and we'll
say this so now we're looking at this
paint this is paint only let's break
this actually down by state so as you
can see when I make a mistake it's very
easy to go and and and change it back to
get the right view of data that I want
to see so now Soleil is editing the
title they're put in a UPS I want not a
text but a box a rectangle to show here
I'll make this transparent I'll make a
single weight line of black and we'll
make it dashed cool and then I'm holding
down the shift key I can actually do
very very small adjustments so now I've
got my
my box showing our awesome work right in
here and then I can say you know look
how well paint performed its look how
well he performed
awesome so then again if I just want to
do the same thing and show this that
this is actually replicable I can
duplicate this page again I come down
here and then now it's not paint but I
want to look at but appliances in the
window so I create a new filter so we'll
call this one appliances include
category equal to appliances I save this
remove the paint filter
then I just move this down get this
aligned right and awesome now I have my
look how well appliances performs so now
in just about 10 or 15 minutes so I have
a clean I have recreated this most of
the demo at least the data within the
demo and we've done this all securely so
we can go back here to the metrics
overview and now it's really cool
another feature that we have within data
studio is the ability not just to share
these so I can now I could come in here
and I could share this report either
with my executives point-to-point
sharing or I could actually share this
with a Google group so let's say there
was a metrics overview group at my
company I could share this with them and
they would automatically have access to
go in and look at this dashboard and
there's different levels of access that
I can give them so with Salette I gave
him access to be able to edit so we
could collaborate in real time on this
report but I also just like a Google
sheet or a Google Doc I can only give
you access so that when people come in
here all they're able to do they can't
mess up my report they can come in here
and all they can do is interact with the
filters that I've put on the page but
there's another distribution model that
we have beyond just point-to-point
sharing where I can go in here and I can
enable embedding of this report so now
this is a private report as Salette
mentioned so we can embed this in our
internal website so that people can come
in on the wiki and be able to see what
you know what we've created from within
within our own site so I'll just quickly
show how to do this on a Google site so
I'll grab this link I'll come in here
this is my sites name foo hardwares west
coast marketing this is what I showed on
my bosses when I want to get promoted I
come in here I stick the embed link in
here I insert here so this is our
overview page and so now I can also add
a text box and say check out how well
you know paint did in the spring and
then I come back here I go to page see
here
page five pays five great
I grabbed this embed URL I embed this in
here and then this is my this is my
paint page so it's really cool is I come
in here to preview this data so this is
what it would look like to my
stakeholders and they would actually be
able to come in here and interact with
any filters that I put on the page so
not only is this a report that I can
share with people but this is actually a
live interactive application that I can
embed inside of my company's own wiki or
blog kind of here and if I made changes
to the report over time to basically
refreshing the page those changes would
be reflected here too right yeah so we
could we could actually look at this
let's say we came here and we went to
page one and I said oh you know I don't
want to look at last year I want to look
at the year before for instance okay or
let's just say I don't want I don't want
to shoot this profit percentage and I
don't want to show this revenue I just
want to show really want to keep the
focus on you know the revenue break down
by department and then I come back in
here and if i refresh this page and go
into preview mode now this report has or
this application or two that I've
created has updated in real time to
reflect the latest changes that I made
on my report that's super cool thanks
for walking through that demo day yeah
no problem I had a little you know demo
gods were not quite with us I realized
what was going on I was in a different
account instead of the sole a dead ones
in any case really great application of
being able to you know create these they
create these data stories and publish
them internally or externally a powerful
tool that it can tell it really
simplifies the process in just a few
minutes it's pretty straightforward to
be able to to be able to create those
stories and find whatever insights you
want to share and send those out to
folks so obviously we encourage all of
you to go try data studio itself as well
again it's a free product so it's really
easy to just click around and explore
connect up to your own data if you'd
like you can import that or you can
connect to some of the public datasets
in bigquery and we urge you all to go
explore that and with that thank you so
much I just wanted to let you know
people have been asking some
questions throughout this presentation
in our live QA and we'll be back in
about less than a minute to answer some
of those questions live so stay tuned
and we'll be right back with that
you
great welcome back to our live Q&A
portion of cloud on air at Google cloud
Dave we got a bunch of great questions
from the audience
our moderator has popped those into a
slide for us to be able to see we get a
ton of great questions over time this is
actually pretty common one as well the
first one how how do people join
different data sets in data studio so
right now we don't have support for
joins within data studio this is
something we're actively working on so
look for this in the near future the
workaround right now is to pump your
data into bigquery and do the join
actually inside of bigquery and then
visualize that inside of data studio
what would I need to be able to do Linda
gray to do that so just write a simple
sequel joint statement equal in a degree
great
how about viewing dashboards on mobile
devices yes so you can view dashboards
on mobile devices you just have to scale
them down because we offer a lot of
flexibility and what you can put on the
page so obviously you can't have as much
granularity on a mobile device so what
we've seen people do is scale down the
number of controls that are on the page
to be able to visualize and access that
information on mobile that makes some
sense and then again using this
internally what access control features
does data studio support for dashboards
and also the underlying data like where
does that data reside right so so the
underlying data always relies in the
underlying data system and there's
multiple models that we support so data
studio is built on top of Google Drive
so right just like you would share a
sheet or a or a Google Doc that's how we
you would share a Google data studio
report right now for the underlying data
you there's different access models for
connecting to the data using both owners
credentials and viewers credentials so
if you set viewers credentials on a data
source then everyone who has access
everyone who wants to render that data
in a report will have to have access to
the underlying data because they'll be
using their their credentials to query
the underlying system make sense thank
you what and then what about connecting
to external data sources we brought this
up in the slide deck oh yeah what is it
sure yes so we connect to a lot of this
is a common question we connect to a lot
of Google data sources Google Ads data
and Google cloud data we also connect to
on Prem data like my sequel and Postgres
and then we have it we're growing an
ecosystem to connect to all sorts of
data around the web so we have over
three
connections to different data sources
around the web and that's constantly
growing so if we don't have it you
actually can go and build it yourself
we've had our UX team even like our
director has built simple connectors and
prototype connectors in under an hour
cool that's great and then talk a little
bit more about how the filters work and
and the different elements that you can
filter by sure yes so we have multiple
types of filters so there's filters
which I showed which are on the page
which you can have at the page level at
the report level or you can even bind to
specific elements so I could say I only
want to filter this one graph by
Department and then I want to compare it
against my overall revenue in another
chart we also have filters that exist at
the Edit what we call the report level
or the editor level so the editors sets
those and these support regex
exclusion in filters greater than or
less than operators for metric filters
and then we also have hands and oars so
there's a lot of flexibility in our
filtering okay and then finally
exporting to PDF yeah so listen you can
you can this is a common request there's
single page export to PDF if you are in
Chrome you can use the the file print to
print to PDF and this is something that
we're looking into for later this year
excellent and that that concludes our
live Q&A portion these were the the top
questions that were bubbled up in our
throughout the presentation so thank you
so much for joining us make sure you
stay tuned for the next section it's
called building for growth the future of
transactional data platforms and system
it's been a ton of fun here thanks Dave
for doing all the demoing thanks for it
yeah and thanks again we'll talk to you
soon